we are gonna begin our welcomes with
teen weekly introducing our event we'll
go into more introductory remarks and
welcomes from the organizers in a little
bit so we're very happy to have been
weekly introducing the first the second
symposium on architectural history
organized by the ph students part of the
architecture inside out syria so mark
okay thanks
nothing really happened to say hello and
welcome to everybody because i can't
resist a few thoughts about your title
leaving to one side the 1940s to 1970s
thing but architecture and the state of
course the the expression i mean
actually in the inuit typography you
have their small and state large but i
think from an analytical point of view
it would be the other way around that
that would be large and state would be
small because it's the effect of that
state the singularity of it which is the
which is the prime which is the primary
effect of state right so one could even
say that state is the effect of that
constructs a sense of that right and i
mean not in the kind of abstract sort of
analytical sense but in a in an everyday
mechanistic sense that this is the the
actual function of so-called state
apparatus is to produce this effect and
of course as you know I'm bound to argue
that this effect is the product of
heterogeneous incompatible forces so the
effect of that is an illusion produced
by its very opposite heterogeneity so
the apparatus of that state or let's say
state apparatus is not and can never be
singular
it can never be what its effect is its
power comes
from this effect right this illusion of
singularity which is the main work of
the state apparatus and it's an illusion
with absolutely real routinely deadly
effects so that would imply that this
conference on architecture in the state
really has to be about architectures
relationship to the heterogeneity rather
than to the singularity if it really
wants to get to get as it were to the
root causes or at least would have to
somehow set up the dialog between what
we think architecture is and the
contradictions kind of veiled within the
effect of that state but of course that
all of this becomes more complicated
because architecture is itself and this
is why the conference is so timely and I
think so interesting is itself a
mechanism for producing the effect of
singularity I mean it's one of the
mechanisms for producing an effect so
then we could reframe the question of
the conference to say the question is
something like what is the complicity or
interdependence of these two effects the
the effect architecture and the effect
State and of course there's this
interdependence is is made obvious in
the ease with which we all to naturally
refer to the architecture of the state
on one side and not at all thinking that
we're entered into some metaphoric
territory on the opposite think to think
that we're moving into some sort of I
was going to say structural but that
would be the very same potential
metaphor we think we are really
encountering the state as it were Aurore
when we describe its architecture but
also in Reverse I think we ought to
naturally think find it easy to think of
architecture as a system of control as
though it were a quasi or mini state
apparatus so having said all of that and
I apologize for this I then become
interested in the titles of each of the
papers because of course in theory
everybody to get into the I mean the
question is how would one choose papers
for conference like this if what I just
said to you is even half true and I
think it's at least three-quarters true
of course the the temptation to choose
papers that have a binary of
architecture on one side and state on
the other which would be the normal way
to proceed is risky and and in that
sense I was kind of statistically about
40% of your titles have the word and in
it like falling into the predictable
pattern but reassuringly for me at least
the remaining 60% have n of heirs by
between through and vs. and from and
maybe that's a kind of limited set and
we would expand that and maybe of course
titles are what you throw at conference
organisers in order to get in through
past the velvet rope and then of course
once you have passed the velvet rope
precisely the point getting into the
club is to do something different so you
have to be someone else to get in and
then be someone else when you're in
that's the point so presumably these
other ways of thinking about the
relationship architecture state are
going to emerge in this in this
conference and what would normally be
regarded as sort of complications if one
thinks for example of so-called
post-colonial theories very extensive by
now even routine the academic
demonstration of the essentially
contradictory nature of colonial
authority self contradictory nature of
this this would it seems to me surely
that we have gone beyond a phase in
which the demonstration of that gives
any kind of pleasure or any kind of
access to tenure for example so there
might be a moment in which the the sort
of joy of demonstrating the
contradictions gives way to something
else and in the context of the state
surely joy would give way to virtual
Terror academic Terror in the sense that
contradictions would be understood to be
more or less directly the agency of
let's say routine violence just sort of
violence with a pattern not anything
other than that so we I think have every
reason to be fearful of contradictions
and I think they
in a certain sense maybe we're so called
it sort of as it were the aftereffect of
post-structuralist philosophy there
there may be two effects one that aren't
interesting one is to announce that it's
gone and that all intelligence is
annoying and you can make a good run for
the White House on that one and then
rebound enthusiastically in a leather
jacket or or actually quite a number of
those arguments have become so deeply
rooted in the academic thinking in in
mechanisms of analysis that the the
effects of that analysis are to use an
old-fashioned word are real that's to
say those that the sort of dismantling
phase or the demystification phase has
given phase two is given way to an
almost an easy proximity between the
operations of analysis and the
operations of power outside of the
university and I think that's it's in
that intersection that I would imagine
that this could be a really good
conference
I could be entirely wrong and this could
be one of the most boring conferences of
the year and in so doing it would become
a really honorable member of this sort
of stodgy Academy but I suspect it's not
going to be like that anyway I'm very
happy that you guys do
we'll see how boring we can get well
hope Thank You Dean weakly for your
opening words and for putting very
elegantly which is gonna struggle to say
in the next 10 minutes I think you
condensed the intention of our
conference very well a special welcome
goes to all the speakers of the
conference who will be taking over it in
a few minutes as soon as we leave the
stage before this happens the three of
us and here I'd like to include a Yala
and we will just lose control of the
event we want to briefly explain the way
we see things for us this conference is
not really about architecture much less
about the state this conference is about
a liaison a relationship namely the one
established between the cultural and use
object that architecture represents and
the mechanisms of power represented by
the state so really in the title the way
we see it the protagonist of our title
is the end as you pointed out the
conjunction that binds architecture and
state together with these we hope to
have proposed not so much a theme based
conference not even a double-headed
theme based conference but a perspective
or a statement of purpose from which to
approach architectural scholarship and
provoke debate this perspective again
concerns the study of the negotiations
constantly at work in this conjunction
to see the different forms at the end
campaign but we take this liaison for
granted the fact that architecture and
build form can never hold escape the its
ideological role our intention for the
next couple of days is not to question
its existence but to dig deep into it
from the role of the state patronage and
politic political ideology in the
development of architectural discourse
to the agency of the architectural
object instead projects our objective is
to inquire into the different modes that
this liaison may take or has taken and
into the struggles and intricacy is
necessary to maintain it afloat reshape
it or break it we are aware that this is
hardly an original proposal arguably
architecture is by definition linked to
power
the state here serves us only as a
placeholder of power of the many
Possible's the most epidemic potential
examples of this link are well-known and
ever present from Haussmann's Paris to
the recent polemics on new housing
settlements in Israel from Chandigarh
and Brasilia to el valle de los gatos
more often than not in these examples
and their study architectures imaginary
support the workings of the state with
our proposed binding of form and
politics without we do not mean to
invoke causality or that any direct
relationship can be assumed between the
architects position and the state or
between a particular style and a
particular socio-political project
precisely what we hope for this
conference is to throw light in the in
the contingency of this relationship and
showcase a matrix of possible links
while still revealing the workings of
architecture as an agent for ideology
this liaison we hope will come out at
the other at the other end of the
conference as a rather dynamic set of
possible relations that was delayed
between instrumentality collaboration
critical negotiation and resistance
ultimately by showcasing these various
options we may be better equipped to
identify at one given point the
boundaries of the discipline the
insights and outside of architecture our
contention is that the period between
nineteen the 1940s and the 1970s proves
particularly fruitful to explore these
dynamics it has already been asserted
asserted by historians as one of state
predominance somewhere in between the
areas of colonial rule and of
globalization for some these are years
to look back to in a defence of the
state for its basis on public consensus
its potential instability and its role
in containing the rise of the private
sector and of capital markets for others
the period serves to decry the state and
its apparatus on the basis of the lack
of flexibility and of individual freedom
proper to centralized economic and
political systems whatever the
historians project the argument runs
that the state in its various models
operated worldwide as a dominant
framework
I said I mean I'm framework for social
political and cultural life was it
whether this was done overtly or not
these narratives take as the overarching
context the processes of the
colonization and the Cold War with
related related polarization of the
world in East and West individual
freedom and collective command and the
various models of welfare state devised
elwell else were somewhat attempt in a
negotiation within this pose so with
this starting point our questions are
quite bluntly whether architectural
research can help better understand this
historiographical argument and
conversely the extent to which this
historical condition myself the study of
the architectural developments of the
time this would help us as a scholars to
move beyond established narratives
centred on autonomous debate on
modernism and its legacy and on modern
masters and their hairs
the question then turns to the position
taken and the strategies devised by the
architects and planners facing these new
political scenarios and to the way the
architectural or urban object may embody
these positions on a larger scale our
intention is to assert architecture both
as a disciplinary discourse with its own
history its own system of knowledge and
set of values but also as a cultural and
political one embedded in the broader
history of the place in which it takes
shape in taking the workings of the
state as one possible material
manifestation of power against which and
within which architecture operates we
open the discussion to a specifics of
the political agency of Architects urban
planners and the architectural object
this will force us to revisit the
language terms and methodology one may
use to approach these historiographical
in this in turn may open up new ways to
effectively better understand and
potentially imagine both new
architectures and new political
scenarios in short the basis of this
liaison that today we make the focus is
that it forces to think and speak of
architecture politically and to think
and speak of the state and at a larger
scale of politics in terms of
architectural and urban form
so based on these premises then the
challenge that we decided to undertake
with the organization of this symposium
was to lay the grounds for an
exploration of the themes the methods
and critical perspectives in current
research and that is of course your
research that could illustrate a
panoramic view of the multi-faceted
liaison between architecture and the
state in this particular period with
this goal in mind our strategy became
precisely to not define any geographic
boundaries political systems or
ideological constructs as the guiding
frame of this conference but instead we
chose to adopt and assess the global
aspect of the role of the states as the
general guideline for this exploration
and to rely on your responses to
indicate the topics that would be at
stake here today the topics that could
reflect many of the positions architects
took during this period visibly the idea
of the states and the works of the state
apparatus so this intentional suspension
of a geopolitical frame adding the
apparently simple terms of the symposium
allowed us to search for difference and
perhaps unforeseen associations among
the proposed topics that then helped
defining the eight themes of the
conference it is through these themes
that the conference
explores how architecture participated
in the rise and consolidation of state
ideologies and its material
manifestations in different state models
so more than the aesthetic construction
of ideological images and particular
histories by the state and of which of
course monumentality becomes its most
visible expression the architect and
urban planner were instrumental in the
States Reorganisation and development of
urban centers and of peripheral and
rural areas and even at a larger scale
we find their intervention in the
occupation of frontier territories and
in the projection of state values and
interests beyond the states borders like
in the particular cases
the American advance and of the Soviet
bloc but this participation of
architecture was never a simple process
some topics will address precisely the
complex mechanisms of implementation and
critique involved in this lesson if on
the one hand State apparatuses attempted
to regulate and mobilize architecture
through the establishment of central
guidelines the constitution of offices
for the clergy isolation or the
bureaucratization of the profession on
the other hand architecture also became
itself an instrument for the critique
for our state projects either by
subverting the state's own mechanisms
from within or through cultural projects
that expose the limits and
contradictions of state policies and
called for its reform architects search
for alternatives to start in positive
force to state in positions while
architectural and urban forms provided
the grounds for wider public
demonstrations it is here between
participation regulation and critique
perhaps a one interesting consequence of
our approach is that each theme proposed
an unexpected reconfiguration of the
ejido graphic territories considered
this way sites that traditionally remain
under studied came to the foreground and
sites that would never be associated or
compared ideologically were now shown
side-by-side under a shared theme so we
could say that the final alignment of
themes came to challenge the fixed
definition of geographies that has
characterized this architecture story
ography and yet the more we avoided a
specific geography the more we were
actually drawing one in this case an
overlapping geographies in continuous
transformation in conclusion the themes
of this conference reflect various
stages during the period between the
1940s and the 1970s where state
ambitions were played in architecture
where architecture played a crucial role
in the realization of state projects but
also where architecture became the voice
to stake what kind of
was desired as an alternative to the one
established and in all the presence of
the state within architectural
Imaginarium practices becomes one of the
traits of the development of
architecture in those four decades so
studying this liaison between
architecture and the States must
inevitably measure the balance between
the architects idea of what the state
should be and what the state effectively
was so having conceived this symposium
as an experiment we now invite you to
join us in exploring the premises and
intentions we just exposed any opening
them for debate but before we leave this
stage to the participants we would like
to thank all of you that have helped us
in making this event possible
in particular Dean Whitley the G SAP and
the Graham foundation that have
supported the inside-out series and
which now comes to a close we would also
like to thank our colleagues in the ph.d
program that have contributed on many
occasions with their help in input
namely James Graham oli amber Kennedy
Diana Martinez
Andrea merits Peter Manoj Alexander
Quantrill and also the assistance of
been proud Sookie Lucia Allegiant and
David inkle with in many matters
involved in the organization of the
symposium finally we also want to thank
our moderators daniel barber Lewis Scott
Anita Reynold Martin and Amelia key
ginger Nolan and Felicity Scott for
their precious collaboration and all of
the participants who arrived from all
continents and who will be the real
protagonist of these two days we also
have two brief final announcements first
to inform you of the last-minute
absences of one of our speakers Alberto
Sato and of Kenneth Frampton who will
not be able to join us tomorrow and
whose panel will be moderated instead by
Ronald Martin and second we also wanted
to ask all of the participants to please
make sure that you have signed and
returned to us the release forms that
were included in your individual folders
so we would now like to give the stage
to Reynold Martin the director of the
ph.d program in the history
in theory of architecture here did she
sell director of the Bureau Center for
American architecture at Columbia and
today the moderator of the first title
of this conference O'Reilly welcome
thank you I you know I have to say that
I am in awe of this group you really you
know just before moving into the panel
itself I really feel the need to to sort
of recognize our organizers we have been
witnessing and silently for the most
part over in the Buell Center and around
the school the the production of the
conference apparatus that is organizing
our two days here you just heard some of
the protocols that have been put in
place about paperwork and you know form
family and so on and and this is only
the tip of a very big iceberg is that
any of you know who have participated
and and more to the point of organized
conferences yourself so so you know it
really must be said that that the
initiative and the imagination of our
organizers has really say and since I
guess the best way to put it would be
has really kind of shown to me at least
a sense of leadership and also
generosity that that is very sort of
reassuring and
and you know makes me optimistic about
about what is to come in this field so
so we're here to see I think some of
that and around these questions that
have already been very compellingly
articulated I I'm not going to add
anything further to the general of
reflections other than to to signal in
advance to the first the participants in
the first panel and maybe to some of you
one of the questions has been in my head
as we've been sort of like indirectly
part of this this process of imagining
and producing this conference which is
to say it is interesting to observe and
define that a major conference like this
is organized at a moment when the
narratives that you know circulating in
rooms like this and universities like
this and like yours are probably
dominated by by the story that says that
around early 1970s what begins to happen
if not sooner is that the state or
States in in whatever form they take or
have taken and to dissolve in favor of
or in lieu of another set of apparatus
is transnational extra state whole and
so on and so forth that channel and
produce power and and circulate
statements of various kinds aesthetic
social political etcetera in different
ways so maybe that's that's something
it's something certainly that came to
mind when I read the papers that I've
had the pleasure of moderating this
morning so a bit of a signal to that one
we might be able to discuss and I'm just
generally in terms of the conference
itself so to get to the business at hand
I will simply introduce our panelists in
the first panel I give you their titles
and then I'll introduce all three and
and then allow them to take the stage
there should be adequate time thereafter
for for the beginnings of what I hope
will be a very interesting two-day
discussion so to begin I'm Trisha Mian
doctoral candidate in archit in
architecture that they call dr. al gilda
a an alpha hormone and the universit de
Partie a wheat and Steve conse conse
divan yzma will present a paper titled
continuity amidst the chaos the reform
of state architectural services in
France 1932 1946 she will be followed by
Anna jozef akka who is a PhD candidate
across the way at the Institute of Fine
Arts at NYU and Anna's paper is titled
drafting at the state design office
architectural the architectural
profession in communist Poland and then
finally joined Knobloch who is a PhD
candidate at the School of Architecture
in Princeton at Princeton University
whose papers title going soft
the architecture of community mental
health centers in the United States 1963
to 1974 so I welcome all of you our
panel and Tricia to set us on our way
thank you
okay so just to begin same advanced just
kind of warning this is an
administrative history so dry but it in
fact is very pertinent to the rethinking
of this period in French architectural
history that's just started to go on
right now in France my desire to study
the creation of the record of the
direction of architecture established
according to official sources in 1945
will come back to this he came a history
beginning fifteen years earlier the
archives revealed that continues percent
pursuit of a reform agenda from 1930 to
1946 unexpected given the economic and
political crises of the 1930s were
followed by the war the occupation the
liberation and the very very difficult
part of the Fourth Republic as just one
indication of the chronic instability of
this time between 1930 and 1946 there
were 45 government's established on
French soil
not counting the reshuffles or the
government's and Algeria
so that's 2.7 governance a year
understanding the continuity of the
reform movement given this context
required a reevaluation of his accepted
historical period as asians sitting
ruptures in 1940 or 1945 for this study
the french state and here i'm going to
use the real name of what's called Vichy
by most people
it's just using its real name so that
the French state could not be treated as
something apart
what's more the Bo's our administration
based in Paris throughout the occupation
remained distant from the marshals
regionalist agenda which is one reason
why I refer to it by its real name as
Pascal Auggie and Kathleen Poulan have
shown during the occupation the bows are
civil servants continued continued
pursuing Popular Front policies sorry
okay sorry okay so that's when we'll see
viola brief history okay so this paper
thus has two major objectives it seeks
to put reforms concerning civil building
services in their context reforms that
triggered the reforms of the state
architectural services while
illustrating the important role of key
civil servants present throughout this
period so for the brief history of the
bechamel steel before the Revolution the
management of royal property was
dispersed and disorganized in 1790 the
constituent assembly began reforming the
state building services distinguishing
between national property what were
called the bhakti most evil the civil
buildings and royal property the Civil
List baby CBO later renamed the national
palaces and it was in the same year they
created the monuments Commission the
interior ministry was charged in 1791
with all three of these elements so here
we have public edifices and monuments
and here we have the National palaces in
what will become later the the core of
the Ministry of National Education but
these three organisms will have very
different in diverse histories before
being reunited in 1929 in 1794 the
deputy Bertram berezovaya Zach called
for the rationalization and
centralization of state building
services because this would be more
efficient less costly and guaranteed
better quality in the
destruction and in the maintenance of
public edifices to this end in 1795 the
Interior Minister Pierre Benedict
created the Coles I can say the abetment
de la rpublique so this is the original
name of the general counsel of civil
buildings and he established missions
that would remain unchanged during its
175 year existence and these missions
are basically sort of a vision of public
service the first was to make sure that
no work is undertaken at the nation's
expense unless the resulting utility
necessity and advantages are evident in
advance the second was to ensure that
the execution of commissions is made
with all the solidity and economy
possible and the third was to examine
the legitimacy of our request for
payment and all complaints that could be
made relative to the construction of
works whether completed in process are
on hold the service and general counsel
of civil buildings were influential
during the first part of the 19th
century even if the centralization of
building services was only partial and
up until now this is the only period
that historians have really been
interested in the battle for the control
of civil buildings between the bows are
in public works administration's
rendered the service and general counsel
itinerant there are 30 weakened with
each transfer and here you can see all
the different attachments of these
services leading up to the period at
1895 which is sort of the moment sort of
the state things are in when I begin
sort of my research the administrative
deconcentration of 1867 in 1871 made
examination by the General Council
optional further weakening their status
deconcentration said means that things
were moved from the central government
in Paris to the departmental governments
run by the Ministry of the Interior by
the beginning of the 20th century the
general council examined mainly its own
services projects very limited in number
and the service no longer had the means
to properly maintain the buildings
classified civil buildings
okay Dujardin bone Metz was under
secretary of state of Bozarth from 1905
to 1912 and called upon the young
academic academic Pollione to help him
reach
organize the bows our administration
because of chronic problems of
overspending delays and completion of
work and scandals linked to poor
construction they implemented state
building service reforms so here are the
the main reforms that they put in place
they restructured both the civil
building in historic monuments
administrations and most importantly in
1907 they reunited civil buildings with
historic monuments the national palaces
are not yet back in the fold the civil
building reforms included the decree of
1911 down here once again requiring
state building projects drawn up by
architects to be examined by the general
council and the service and general
counsel began to see a slight increase
in activity but that was quickly brought
to halt by the war sort of ending this
first attempt at reform the
administration but Pollione will remain
in the bows our administration from 1905
to 1933 which helped explains the link
between the initiatives before World War
one and the early 1930s to RIBA ginn
reforming Pollione indeed overlaps with
the next generation of administrators
who arrived in the bows our
administration just before or just after
World War one of the three most
important of the story we have the
architect Robert Denis who enters in
into the bows our administration in 1913
after passing the competitive entry
exams to become both an architect of
civil buildings and historic monuments
and for these three actors I don't have
time to completely sort of go into their
careers here but just to show that they
were for very many many years very
involved in the bosons and architectural
service administration's mobilized
during the war
danice's efforts to save monuments in
the eastern sector revealed his
administrative capacities afterwards
he's charged with creating and running
Bo's art institutions in Alsace Lorraine
also a respected educator Denis is
active in the Bo's our administration
until his death in 1949 so a very very
long career then of course the
much-maligned Louis Oetker and it's not
the greatest picture sorry about that
an architectural historian is mobilized
and wounded during the Great War before
being assigned to a diplomatic mission
with the President ducros I the
president of course I would be like it's
a bit like the Prime Minister but with a
lot more power than the Prime Minister
today so that kind of super Prime
Minister in 1920 he enters into the bows
our administration as an assistant
conservator at the Louvre he proves
himself an able administrator effective
in creating and reforming bows our
institutions
revoked by the French state in 1944 he
is reintegrated in 1946
and retired thus ending his involvement
in the bozer administration the last
arrival is Hani Pasha who was mobilized
during the Great War
and severely wounded losing a leg after
studying law he passes the competitive
entry exam in 1921 to become an
administrator in the direction of Bazar
where he is assigned to the office of
civil buildings he remains in the civil
building services until he becomes
director of architecture in 1940 then
holding either the number one or two
positions in architecture until his
retirement in 1963 after World War one
france faces serious financial
difficulties in 1920 the positions of
bows are division directors are
eliminated there was one for
architecture and one for arts and these
were combined into one position of the
director of bazar and this is attributed
to paly young between 1922 and 1929
public expenditures decrease in
comparison to the gross domestic product
a sign of the times in 1925 the general
council finds itself at
about and having been consulted on only
seven dossier in the whole year new
tendencies finally begin to appear in
1928 when the ministry elevates the Bo's
our administration from a jet direction
to a general direction that's bringing
more positions and more financing then
in 1929 the National palaces these are
the things appear the national palaces
are finally reunited with civil
buildings and historic monuments and we
see that as of 1929 there's also a
series of Public Works programs that the
government begins to finance with money
set aside for civil buildings projects
and it's in 1930 when the public
expenditures in relation to the gross
domestic product finally begin to
increase so this is the moment when sort
of the the reform agenda comes back to
life faced with new activity and
emergence of scandals regarding state
buildings in the late 1920s buildings
not controlled by the civil building
services Pollione revives the
revolutionary idea of centralizing and
rationalizing state building services by
reinforcing the general counsel of civil
buildings to decrees in 1930 and 1932
expand the range of projects that must
be submitted to the General Council
while the decree of 1930 also charges
the prefect with assuring that the
buildings are constructed according to
approve plans which made sense at the
time because it was the prefect who
awarded the building permits the next
general director of bizarre immunity
bola came from the prefecture services
and was former director of cabinets of
Edward ikuyo when he was the president
of Kansai so this kind of super prime
minister at the head of bazaar from
December 1932 until February 1934 he
reinforces the civil building services
by creating a construction management
office to handle the demands of this
economic stimulus building programs the
arrival of career administrator Josh
Weissman as general director of Bo's art
from February 1934 into July 1940
signals a new phase in the
movement Wiesman a dynamic personality
was general secretary for the president
of the republic paul do mayor until
Damaris assassination in May 1932 he
understood very well the workings of the
government who Eastman's first reforms
for architecture of 34 and 35 had to
dealt with the increased workload coming
from the special credits programs he
augments the number of seats for
architects in the general council and
creates a a position of associated
general inspector in a Juwan first
attributed to robert Denis and this is
when Denis becomes more important in the
central administration the success of
the Popular Front movement founded in
July 1935 leads to jean J's appointment
is minister of national education from
June 1936 to September 1939 which was a
really long time given the number of
governments that came in one at the time
and his initiative served to kirsta lies
and accelerate the reform movement
shortly after his nomination
zey sends the niece to study the Office
of Public Works in England a model for
the next reform renewing explicitly with
the revolutionary vision the June 1938
legislation here major reform was a
major reform of the General Council and
outlined the complete centralization of
state building services the details of
which are under study when the war
breaks out the decree law also now
requires that the General Council
examine all buildings built with state
subsidies so for example a lot of
municipal schools had state subsidies
with the war approaching starting in
August of 1939 the ministry evacuates
the bows our administration from Paris
Grenada che is in charge of the
administration now based in the Loire
Valley New Yorker participates in the
evacuation of artworks from the National
Museums and Robert Denis is mobilized
after the defeat in mid July 1940 the
bows our administration returns to Paris
directly and Louie Oetker becomes
general director of bows our his first
initiative and which is the one up here
at the top in red is a reorganization of
the
our administration on December 1st 1940
which includes the creation of the
direction of state architectural
services in order to prepare for the
central centralization of building
services as legislated by the decree law
of June 1938 so he continues with the
front popular policy
he names Ren a parish a the first
director this is a first step in major
reforms not only of state architectural
services but also of the profession and
education of Architects briefly listed
here we don't have time to talk about
that today but it's also very
interesting his other reforms the first
Constituent Assembly of the provisional
government of the French Republic
dominated by the left seek to go further
with the Popular Front reforms and
October of 1944 the National Education
Minister honey capital a Gollust of the
left name's mark Shea interim general
director of bizarre and charges da nice
with assuring the direction of
architecture the ordinance of 1944 which
is a the one at the top elevates the
direction of state architectural
services to the general direction of
architecture now independent of Bazar
and attached directly to the minister
capita the names Donnie's general
director of architecture in December
1944 before reintegrating Parish a and
the services of architecture in January
1945 as director of buildings palaces
and urban ordinances as well as interim
director of historic monuments so the
the general direction had two directions
and parish A's at the top of both of
them Donnie's and parish a participate
in elaborating the new general
directions structure approved on August
18 1945 which is here and this is often
given as the official date of the
founding of the direction of
architecture which is not the case but
it's an attempt to hide the fact that it
was created during Vichy the key reforms
of architecture are now in place by the
time the Parliament shifts towards the
center with the elections of June 1946
on the eve of the birth the birth of the
Fourth Republic the structures of a
great architectural service as imagined
by Jean J are finally in place
the first government of the fourth
republic inaugurated on January 21st
1947 must face the country's dire
economic and material conditions the
emergence of the Cold War in March 1947
and the government's desire to benefit
from the Marshall Plan result in the
revocation of communist ministers in May
1947 and the most radical of the social
ministers in October of that year by
October of 1951 the definitive shift of
the government to the right arises on
any level excludes socialists from
ministerial appointments in parallel the
Ministry of Reconstruction and urbanism
the mru growing quickly began to imagine
its temporary existent as permanent and
in early 1947 requested control of the
general direction of architecture but
the Popular Front dream of creating a
Ministry of Arts is still alive and
architecture represented 80 percent of
the total bizarre budget at the time we
smen now state councillor and member of
the a permanent member of the General
Council of civil buildings urges the
rapid reestablishment of the general
direction of bizarre reuniting arts and
architecture with architecture now
reduced to a direction in hopes of
preventing the transfer a recommendation
implemented in August of 1947 this
Forces Dhoni's into retirement although
he remains active as honorary general
director and parish a becomes re becomes
the director of architecture the
question of the attachment of the
direction of architecture is not over
yet complicated by the fact that the
Ministry of National Education insists
on keeping control of historic monuments
while not insisting on the same for
civil buildings the initial risk of
transfer is now compounded by the risk
of the breaking up of services that are
finally after 40 years of effort
integrated in early May 1950 the
national economics Commission decides to
transfer modern buildings to the mru
while leaving
historic buildings with Bazar despite
the Central Committee of investigations
recommendations against this because of
the additional expenditures that this
separation would create bear Shea leads
the battle against this decision even if
not overturned it will not be
implemented
despite this reprieve the tides of
definitively turned
the reform movement for the direction of
architecture it is not a question of
survival in guise of a conclusion I
would like to briefly say a few words
about why the continuous presence and
influence of the principal actors was
possible during such an unstable period
first the Third Republic early on sought
to deep politicize civil servants
political affiliations were only
supposed to be a factor for high-level
appointments long-term support of the
reform movement in architecture came
from career civil servants who spent
their careers in the services of
architecture or in bazaar and their aim
was to create the best public service
possible for the management of state
edifices their convictions were based on
the pragmatic concerns that came from
the day-to-day management of these
buildings secondly it was precisely the
civil servants who kept the
administrative administration's
functioning despite during these years
despite the revolving doors on the
minister's offices also countering the
instability it was common to see
ministerial portfolios colonized by a
political party or a group of closely
aligned parties the ministers during
this period are on two sides here we go
through the French state and you can
just see the most of the ministers from
the thirty public our centre left and
left affiliated so this is certainly the
case for the National Education Ministry
except during the French state when it's
attached to these left more left-wing
ministers the banishment of the left
from from the governments between 1947
and 1951 is one reason why the radical
ministers charged with national
education down here especially as of
1951 with on prime Fe are aligned with
centrist rather than left his tendencies
thirdly the modernization of all state
administrations is a government
objective starting with the economic
crisis of the 1930s and has pursued at
the end of the Third Republic by the
French state and by the provisional
government with often very similar
objectives and here
about the Civil administration's what's
more the reforms being prepared by the
Popular Front stopped short by the war
were in a sense ready and waiting
so at each major restructuring of the
state the civil servants responded
rapidly with propositions already
thought through this is why the front
popular policies carried on so long this
is one reason why many in the Bo's our
administration found themselves at a
loss and confronted with the first
governments of the technocratic Fourth
Republic who put bean counters in charge
of reforming administration's pursuit
through the logic of eliminating
positions the efficient delivery of good
public service the predominant concern
since nineteen thirty was no longer the
objective
yes
they're coming
in Poland in the aftermath of World War
two the architectural profession became
deeply politicized as did all
professions a condition fostered by
Poland self-appointed communist
leadership the Charen the changes
implemented the chain the changes
implemented were to facilitate poland's
transformation into a subsidized
socialist state a major departure from
pawns pre warriors in which was the cut
in which the communist party had been
outlawed outlawed since 1919 within
architecture the most well known
manifestation of the state's direct
heavy-handed oversight was the 1949
declaration of the Socialist Realist
doctrine a set of officially sanction
directives for the country's
architectural profession as to how it
would contribute to the creation of
socialist Poland best now for
stipulating the new architectures formal
language the doctors for male socialists
and content and national inform
translated in the speeches of the
party's architectural ideologues into
the condemnation of modernism and
embrace of historicizing
architecture Broca rooted in local and
soviet classical academic traditions
these guideposts resulted in a plethora
of projects in which classicizing
architectural forms were inscribed with
figurative relief sculpture of
monumental eyes party leaders and
workers few of which would actually be
realized the enforcement of specific
aesthetic guidelines in effect from 1949
to 1956 was however not the only
mechanism that the state authorities
used to alter and exercise control over
the country's architectural production
nor was it the most profound in terms of
lasting effect addressing this less
discussed aspect of the doctrine the
following paper focuses on the structure
of architects work environment
instituted by the authorities in the
late 1940s as a strategy to incorporate
architecture into the larger building in
the
three and and as part of the effort to
better meet the objectives of the
six-year economic plan in effect from
1950 to 1956 also known as the six-year
plan for the building of socialist
Poland this ambitious ideologically
charged state and ever fast-tracked an
extensive urbanization and
industrialization of the country placing
the building industry architecture
included on top of the national agenda
and in the crosshairs of ideological
scrutiny with 60% of the plans overall
budget allocated to the building
industry the demands and expectations
placed on architecture were high for the
architectural profession the reforms
commenced in April 1948 with the
announcement of the nationalization of
the architect architectural practice
through the creation of the state design
bureaus centralizing pawns entire
architectural workforce with this move
the state authorities discontinued the
pre-existing framework of the country's
architectural profession namely the
small and media to medium sized private
design studios offering a wide range of
architectural services to private and
public clients alike according to the
authorities
private architectural practice was
incompatible with the nationalized
economy the new methods of financing and
the organization of production
championed by the state a new type of
work environment and method was required
to integrate the architectural
profession into the system in which
there is only one client one investor
and one contractor the state following
those decisions private architectural
practice was outlawed in 1949 and
registered architects immediately
received work assignments steepler
stipulating were to report house at
first in temporary facilities in the
early 1950s the state design bureaus
were relocated to offices specifically
built for the purposes situated in the
country's major cities the large
concentration were to be found in
in the capital or so under the direct
control of the Ministry of Building and
the state commission of economic
planning as well as more specific brand
specific branches of the economy heavy
industry for example the design bureaus
fulfilled commissions for all buildings
budgeted for construction within the
given economic plan estate production
enterprises the bureaus were not
comprised of architects alone
but also incorporated non architectural
management administrative support staff
as well as variety of building
technicians architects a minority within
the bureaus were distributed amongst the
smaller studios most of which were
comprised composed of no more than
several members in the mid-1960s trained
architects constituted only 10 to 15% of
bureau's overall employee count the
great size of the buildings housing the
bureau's did not reflect the extent of
the country's architectural workforce
but rather the extent of administrative
oversight under the new system
architects were categorized as office
workers given the primary task to
manufacture architectural drawings
officially reference as technical
documentation the drafting work was
subject to the same management
guidelines as thousand effect for other
state on production facilities the
adopted measures reflected the central
administration's commitment to
rationalization and standardization of
architectural production most important
of the social Israel is Mata was the
exercise of economic discipline on the
part of the workers in which all
activity required substantiation of real
necessity backed by official order and
carry it forward with utmost economic
efficiency all management decisions
implemented with the state design
bureaus aim to increase productivity and
reduce production costs with the
prescribed 8-hour workday the architects
were pressured to me the servants to
pass given quotas the architects work
schedule define how many hours
Studios should spend producing an
elevation or section and how much
material tracing paper was to be used to
achieve this that assignment in
producing technical documentation
architects was responsible for
conferring with technical ex experts
also employees of the bureaus to produce
appropriate documentation for electric
work planning etc and ensuring that
every set of design needs the approval
of various economic and design
committees set up on departmental and
state levels every team was obliged to
deliver status reports at monthly
briefings he'll pay the bureau's
management in 1952 a warsaw
architectural studio was allocated 1338
hours to develop a design concept and a
full set of technical drawings for a
proposed cultural club with nine
thousand three hundred cubic meters of
space when calculated this gives studi
approximately 14 hours from start to
finish for each approved drawing
required for the complete set of
documentation such work conditions gave
the viewers their unofficial name of the
design factories one architect described
the conditions of which the work during
the 1950s and 1960s as its assembly line
for production of technical
documentation carried out within the
noise of large offices by randomly
assembled teams of architects with well
what was effectively extrapolated from
the state design bureaus was research
that that prior to nationalization was
swans
integral to the design process under the
new system research and experimentation
were delegated to special special
research institutes also stabbed by
architects engineers and technology
experts responsible for creating design
guidelines
- evident establishing building
standards and developing typical design
elements which would then be supplied to
the design bureaus as drafting aid their
use was
the purpose of this decentralized
research center was to establish
uniformity in uniformity in the
technical documentation produced
nationwide as well as to streamline the
design work perform at the bureaus it
would be incorrect to assume that the
new system and the work methods embrace
eradicated the traditional view of
architecture understood in terms of
immersion of art and technology
although limiting the formal language
available the state expected out most
creativity from its public servants in
the interpretation of the social
Australis doctrine architects continued
to be rewarded for innovation while
architectural students that in the
future state design bureau employees
were taught that architecture was a
creative process its end result an
expression of Architects subjective
vision
moreover the institutional structure of
the state design bureaus continued to
cultivate the notion of architecture
authorship and mastery of the profession
studio active within any given Bureau
allowed individual architects to develop
and maintain privileged positions based
on professional recognized
accomplishment the studios follow a
clerical personnel structure not
dissimilar to that of privately operated
design Italia at the bottom were the
least experienced members of the team
usually recent graduates whose position
equal to that of apprentice starting as
assistants in time they would gradually
rise to the position of designers
followed by the title of senior designer
and eventually head of studio each
studio and the work it produced would be
identified by its assigned number but
also by the name of the chief designer
who would be considered the leading
author of the work produced under
his/her or her direction due to the
state's control of all media it is
difficult to obtain a balanced
assessment
of this day design bureaus effect on the
profession this especially is this is a
special true in regards to the era of
the search of socialist realism one of
the more repressive and propagandistic
periods of communist rule in Poland but
even reading between the lines one sense
is that in general architects master
lilyc enthusiasm for the nationalization
of their profession a survey of the
1950s popular press and issues of our
affectaura the main architectural
publication of communist Poland revealed
that the country's architectural
profession framed the practices that
characterize the state design bureaus as
a threat to a good socialist
architecture the negative reaction to
the announced plans to form the bureaus
were likely instantaneous and equally
politicized already the 1948 official
statement announcing the state design
bureaus took a defensive tone and was
delivered to a quote skeptical audience
the state design offices it was
underlined would provide freedom from
the burden of time-consuming bureaucracy
bureaucratic procedures such as securing
building permits registrations and
approvals as well as as well as afford
architects protection from the
uncertainties of employment present
under free market conditions
moreover the new work framework would
guarantee that architects who see their
projects realized as only pre-approved
Building Commission's with secured
funding would be passed along to the
design offices most important were the
assurances that the new institutions
would not strip the architects of their
authorship or disregard the creative
component of design process efforts
would be made that the bureaus would not
turn into monstrous bureaucratic
machines but rather support the and
nurture the creative process that goes
into producing high-quality designs by
those who perform it the work in the
state design bureaus was commonly
described as lacking
and any requirement for creative process
our allowances for experimentation the
way the bureau's were managed in the
opinion of the employed architects only
cultivated routine and this interest on
the part of the architects the speed
with which the architectural studios
were required to deliver materials to
meet deadlines did not allow for proper
thought processes to be carried out
leaving architects all alienated from
their own designs and dissatisfied with
the end results the system of work
oversight and multi-tier approval
process was detrimental to the
architects sense of responsibility and
authorship to clarify his point point
about the complexity of the bureaucratic
structure and cumbersome time-consuming
approval process faced by the architects
the outer of a 1956 article for example
included a diagram that illustrated the
process through which an architectural
architect of a design in this case alpha
housing estate had to go through in
order to have the design approved and
passed on to the state contractor in
scrap wood within the circle is an
endless meandering line representing the
two-year path an arc trip design was
obliged to follow in order to fulfill
all the requirements and pass through
various verification committees
resembling a labyrinth the diagram does
little for a for understanding of the
system in place other than to suggest
that it was hardly decipherable even for
the initiative the architectural
community used the platform of its own
professional organization the Society of
Polish architects to call meetings
issued recommendations and petition
central authorities to improve the work
situation and augment regulations dating
back to 1934 the Society of Polish
architects by no means was an
independent organization financed by the
state and subject to state oversight
their organization nevertheless aim to
fulfill its mission statement and served
by acting in its best interest without
direct party affiliation and run by
architects elected to their house by
fellow members it provided the community
with a platform for a professional
discussion about issues pertinent
pertinent to the condition of the
profession upon the creation of the
state design bureaus the society
concentrated its efforts on the issue of
architectural creativity code for
freedom from state oversight in its
place under the new system its ultimate
agenda was to alter the organizational
structure of the bureau's and architects
work routine in 1953 for example Patras
by survey circulating circulated among
the employees of select bureaus who
voiced their dissatisfaction with the
work atmosphere and routine of the
bureau's the Society issued a
recommendation addressed to the state
Advisory Council to reintroduce special
hours within their work architects
workweek that would be dedicated to
creative exploration it granted the
architects if granted the architects
would use the time to dedicate
themselves to study in research of
design problems an important tradition
prior to nationalization and maintained
by the Society of Polish architects was
a supervisor was to supervise
architectural competition organized on
behalf of public or state institutions
juried by the members of the community
community together for reproof
representative I'm sorry with those
representing the commissioning
institutions and state economic
authorities however during the realist
Socialist Realist era few competitions
were called and those that were held
were by invitation only and there
without society's direct involvement
following the thaw the Society made the
case that their competitions held a key
to preventing polish socials
architecture from stagnation and regress
counterbalancing the work performed at
the design bureaus in 1956 the
competitions were described as the arc
that's independent salons in instances
in which the designers could fully
explore the subject at hand an
especially strong message in the in this
regard was sent by the society in 1956
in connection with the competition
number 213 which sought proposal for a
Polish embassy building in Beijing the
architectural jewelry chart with
evaluation of the quality of designs and
constituted by members of the society
rewarded prizes to projects that did not
meet the competition guidelines and so
we're automatically disqualified from
realization the practice introduced at
this critical moment upon Poland's
political history in which architectural
jurors disregarded the competition
requirements thus rewarding architects
for design innovation alone was never
approached by the authorities but in
fact accepted in the opinion of the one
communist era architects stretched
structured architectural competitions
were recognized as relatively harmless
ways to bring some satisfaction to
professionally frustrated architects
well the cash prize is supplied by the
state they also cast the regime in a
positive light transforming the state in
a patron of architecture in 1956 the
aesthetic guidelines declared and the
Socialist Realist doctrine were rebuked
by the state authorities and
characterized as a mistake and desire
and distortion of socialist values
advanced by temporarily misguided party
leadership other aspects of the doctrine
however continued in effect throughout
the Communist period the professional
remaining to a greater extent
nationalist night until 1989 in 1957 the
authorities allowed for existence of
limited design cooperatives and in 1983
Theory sanctioned private practice
efforts to rationalize design practice
within the country's state design beers
resisted as did the directors for the
cost-cutting measures which after 1956
were re-energized by wholehearted
raise of prefabrication in building
construction polish architects polish
architects steadily over the years
criticized the organizational system in
place repeatedly complaining that it was
detrimental to the quality of
architectural design architects who
practiced under the system have pointed
out that quality of Polish architecture
of communist era should not be judged
based on what was actually built in
Poland a reflection of our ill-founded
dysfunctional bureaucratic system
matched by sap for construction work and
poor quality materials rather the ear
should be judged by unexecuted designs
specifically entire entries to
architectural competitions in the
opinion of one architect the project
submitted to communist-era competitions
externalize the ideas and hopes for of
architects which are otherwise
effectively suppressed so the routine of
office work in the course of the Polish
People's Republic over 700 competitions
were held while he contributed to with
many exceeding over 100 entries since
the competitions involve prize money
they were important sources of the
additional income a powerful incentive
for underpaid state office workers
however becoming a financial successful
competitor was not achieved by winning
first prizes among the most after
sought-after prizes were the second
prize finishes which provided the
recognition of the architectural
community financial gain but not carry
the risk of construction in 1977 the
tongue-in-cheek article an experienced
participant and juror of architectural
competitions presented his colleagues
with a winning formula in which he
factored all the variables including
during makeup was architecture Percy
president's graphic presentation amount
of labour and so on while encouraging
the practice of entering competitions
here at the same time warned the readers
against aiming too high in winning the
first prize emphasizing the inheritance
dangers the unfortunate overall winner
would face years of maneuvering thick
and convoluted bureaucracy growing
frustrated of a financial and technical
restrictions battling countless approval
commission all in order to see them now
unrecognizable project through faced
with these prospects the author of the
article concluded that first prize
winner may as well give up and move to
France being hired as a draftsman in one
of the large architectural bureaus there
will be more satisfying than being an
author of a really ice building in
Poland beginning in the 1950s as the
architects death bound future within
design bureaus crystallized and the
architect found himself no longer
welcome at the construction site
professional pressure on the state to
offer outfits for the relative autonomy
since lost resulted in the increased
number of unpopularity of open
competitions the desired second-place
finish with its cash reward and freedom
from institutional oversight ironically
would bring the competitor no closer to
the site thank you
Thank You Emma and now finally join our
walk
to start I'd like to thank the
organizers for this opportunity and I'd
like to thank you all for coming going
soft the architecture of community
mental health centers in the United
States 1963 to 1974
in 1963 dr. Robert Felix the director of
the National Institute of Mental Health
offered American architects the
opportunity to design a new type of
psychiatric institution in an essay
published in dark in architectural
record dr. Felix claimed that architects
would be able to use their ingenuity to
determine the shape of a new typology
which he hoped would become as much a
part of community life as the elementary
school or post office there was reason
to be so ambitious as earlier that year
President John F Kennedy had signed the
community mental health centers Act a
program that aimed to build a national
system of 2,000 facilities to meet the
mental health needs of all Americans
regardless of their ability to pay the
community mental health centers were to
be a new permeable institution which
would provide psychiatric care on a
mostly outpatient basis in facilities
located within the patient's community
instead of remote residential
institutions in order to avoid the
design mistakes of the past and to
create a new image for psychiatric care
the National Institute of Mental Health
foster design research which brought
architects in contact with a group of
psychiatrists who enriched the architect
sensitivity to the patient population
similarly the architects brought two
psychiatrists and the NIH a knowledge of
design enriched by an articulated form
of modern architecture and the young
field of architectural programming the
result was a unique refinement of the
program driven architecture of the
1960's which stands as a reflection of
the welfare programs of the Great
Society and the growing expertise of
social science most suggestively the
community mental health centers can be
read as a new architectural strategy
suited to an increasingly democratic
increasingly psychologize biopolitical
society dr. Felix is called Architects
in architectural record was only a small
part of a larger collaboration and only
the start of the National Institute of
Mental Health's promotion of the
collaboration between architects and
psychiatrists on the subject of
community mental health centers in the
same year the NIH appointed an architect
Clyde Dorset shown here to oversee the
grant application
process a process which included three
stages of drawing submissions schematic
preliminary and working drawings but
nothing compared to the previous
diagrams of process a few years later
Dorset and the ni MH sponsored a
prototype study for a San Francisco
facility by architects ellis kaplan and
herbert mclaughlin in concert with two
psychiatrists dr. joseph j downing and
robert eek image the san francisco study
was published as a large award-winning
volume which was intended to serve as an
early guideline for potential applicants
to the CMHC program following the san
francisco study the National Institute
of Mental Health sponsored the third
annual rice design fete at Rice
University the rice design FET consisted
of an intensive two-week working session
for gathering of the top architects and
psychiatrists at work on new
institutional designs six pairs of
architects and psychiatrists
participated in the rights to that
design fete and each pair was
responsible for directing a group of
five architecture students and one
community mental health trainee as they
developed their scheme each team started
with a different American community in
need of a center and the teams were to
use the demographics aesthetics and
programmatic needs of the community as
the basis for their design while the
information was taken from actual
locations in the United States the
locations were used anonymously to stand
in for prototypical communities yielding
subtypes of community mental health
centers the six types were Metro
suburban rural research oriented urban
slum ghetto state and General Hospital
Midwestern rural and heterogeneous urban
the design schemes ranged from a long
linear bridge between the hospital in
the community in the proposal by
architect William Caudill and doctor
Alfred Paul Bay to McKinley and Foley's
scheme for a quote continuous form where
the facility was broken down into
smaller elements whose programmatic
components were further articulated as
separate volumes architect ehe Azumi
continued a longer collaboration with
dr. Humphrey Osmond but instead of
producing a building design Azumi
produced a diagrammatic language of
nested circles indicating the various
company
Asians of individual and group spaces in
his scheme Azumi and Osmonds team
started with the census data for their
catchment area of a hundred and fifty
thousand people somewhere in the
southwestern US the team identified the
area as composed of various ethnic and
social groups ranging from suburban
residents to quote hillbillies their
strategy was to create an environment
where such diverse persons could be
encouraged slowly to interact with each
other in increasingly larger groups an
idea they Ellis trated in the diagrams
the architects of community mental
health centers learned a great deal from
their interaction with psychologists
though of course architects like William
Cottle were already in pursuit of
programming expertise by this time and
in formal terms while Allison and Peter
Smith's ins how to recognize and read
mat building was not published until
1974 Architects such as the Smithson
Zelda Van Eyck and Louie Kahn had
already been producing articulate
articulated low-rise forms similar to
several of the schemes for anti
monumental community mental health
centers but even as the community mental
health center designs built on ideas
that were already present in the field
of architecture the opportunity offered
by dr. Felix the ni MH and by extension
the federal government of the United
States gave the architects the chance to
share information to develop ideas and
to focus on the problem of designing
within a society whose everyday life was
increasingly psychologize the infusion
of psychology expertise into American
culture after World War two produced a
number of patients who inhabited a far
greater area between mental health and
mental illness than had been a case even
20 years earlier delinquency alcoholism
and even family dysfunction were coming
under the domain of the psychologists
care making formerly well patients into
sick patients and at the other end of
the spectrum pharmacology and a drive
for deinstitutionalization meant that
many who had formerly have been
committed to remote facilities were no
longer being hidden the way the rising
influence of the ni MH itself reflects
the growing status of psychology but it
also reflects the federal government's
growing involvement in the mental health
of its citizen population prior to World
War two the only federal agency devoted
to mental health was the division of
Mental Hygiene
an organization responsible for
screening new immigrants ferment a
soundness treating drug addiction and
providing counseling to federal or
present federal prisons in 1949 the NIH
was formed as a cabinet-level agency
within the National Institute of Health
which was itself part of the Department
of Health Education and Welfare the
budget of the NIH grew rapidly from
eight point seven million in 1950 to 315
million in 1967 as they grew the nimas
budget and influence led them to conduct
extensive research outside of a
laboratory or psych its a key at Raqqah
spittle in an attempt to justify their
role and to compete within the also
expanding National Institutes of Health
around them by 1964 a majority of the ni
mh's research budget was spent on work
that was not directly related to
psychiatry or biological sciences
supported by the Great Society agenda to
expand what historian Alice O'Connor
calls poverty knowledge the NIH studied
the cycle of mental illness and poverty
as well as urban and architectural
factors of mental health spawning even a
Center for the study of metropolitan
problems but where those were primarily
research programs the community mental
health centers act included a large
construction program which was in
essence a commitment by the federal
government to community-based mental
health care for all of its citizens
because of the increasingly broad
definition of mental health this program
would study the demographics of an urban
population as in these maps from the San
Francisco study that I mentioned earlier
but the community mental health center
program was also tasked with
constructing community-based
institutions engaged in the prevention
of delinquency alcoholism and other
socially destructive conditions despite
the importance of key professional and
political motivations for
deinstitutionalization such as the
efforts of the group for the advancement
of psychiatry better known as gap
perhaps the movement out of the hospital
was only possible because of a new act a
new class of psychoactive drugs
indeed the drugs had such an impact on
treatment then one can argue that the
community mental health centers would
never have existed without psychotropic
drugs introduced in 1955
Thorazine was the most commonly known
commercial variant of
promazine which was itself the product
of research on the potential for
histamines to be used as a sedative for
surgery the drug produced a state of
calm and unconcerned in patients
allowing many to wake up and begin to
speak but the drug also created the
zombie-like patient familiar from films
of mental hospitals by the early 1960s
Thorazine and similar drugs had advanced
to the point that they made it possible
for many patients to function somewhat
normally outside of an institution the
biological restraint provided by the so
called chemical straightjacket had a
profound impact on the amount of
physical restraint that the architecture
needed to provide thus making the
community mental health center possible
even the patients who needed inpatient
care could be allowed greater freedom
within the walls of the new institution
psychoactive drugs internalized the
architecture of restraint altering the
internal environment of the patient's
mind and freeing up the external
architecture as would later be commented
on by architects Hans whole line and Ron
Herren indeed this conception of the
community mental health center as anti
restraint was presented in an NIH
publication through a graphic
juxtapositioning of a restraining
mechanism known as a Utica crib which is
on table with the architecture of the
community mental health center in a
sense the drugs made it possible for the
environmental controls to be dissolved
into the individual patients brain
chemistry unsurprisingly then the
internalization of control was
frightening to many particularly by the
late 1960s and early 1970s as criticisms
of psychiatric psychiatry generally and
the community mental health centers
program specifically grew for example in
1968 dr. Kenneth Kenaston published an
essay called how community mental health
stamped out the riots 1968 to 1978 said
even he has a defined time chronicling a
fixed shifts fictitious operation
inner-city which followed a strategy of
total saturation of psychology experts
to finally stop the riots another
psychiatrist hi i'm shaytan accused the
community mental health center program
of setting up quote a government
subsidized conveyor-belt and quote which
led psychiatrists to adopt the
techniques of the modern factory using
management tools instead of seeing many
disorders as behavioral adaptations to
larger social
issues given the late-1960s context of
racial tensions urban riots and the
targeting of community mental health
centers to low-income populations it is
understandable that the use of drugs
made many people uneasy in order to
quell such concerns
Thorazine and a similar drug stelazine
were advertised to psychiatrists as a
modern tool for a modern psychiatry
using so-called primitive art as a foil
against which to make the comparison
juxtaposing the paraphernalia smooth
blue pills sleek eyedroppers and brown
glass containers with the organic forms
fuzzy hair and smiling face of a
so-called primitive art object one ad
for stelazine from 1976 emphasized the
modernity of the drugs well at the same
time naturalizing them a similar ad for
Thorazine called the drugs the basic
tools of western psychiatry comparing
them to the basic tools of primitive
psychiatry exemplified by religious art
from Togo in Africa there was some
confusion in the captions of the
advertisements sometimes they're placed
in tango but they're from Togo this
attempt to show drugs is simply the more
advanced reliable modern form of a very
old basic practice had definite racial
overtones given the choice of African
art as the background for the modern
pills other advertisements made the
connection between drugs and race even
more clearly as in the Haldol
advertisement featuring a burning
building and an african-american shaking
his fists as described by historian
Jonathan Metzl in order to evaluate
whether the politics of psychopathy
psychopharmacology or the communion
mental health center program itself were
Liberatore or repressive we will have to
frame the political conditions that
inhabited for while the advent of
psychopharmacology indies and
deinstitutionalization
changed the architectural manifestations
of psychiatry and the relation of the
state to its citizenry it was only a new
turn in a political era that was
considerably older that of biopolitics
writing in the 1970s about changes in
18th century France Michel Foucault
described a shift from the era of
sovereignty where in power was exerted
by the sovereigns right to take life to
a situation characterized by the
administrator
life in short and tomorrow a more recent
formulation from architectural theorist
to spend all of Wallenstein
quote the body politic becomes a living
entity that must be attended to not just
a source of disturbances that must be
repressed end quote
the bio political model the centers
around the concept of a living
population which can be defined by two
features in order to be considered a
population a group must be conceived of
as a hiroji Gnaeus mix of individuals a
statistically describable plurality
which is conceived of as quasi natural
or akin to a population of animals the
second criteria is that the population
serve as a political force a collective
entity that can offer a surface on which
state power is exerted Foucault argued
that the complexity of this demographic
surface means quote the relationship
between the population and the sovereign
cannot simply be one of obedience or the
refusal of obedience of obedience or
revolt if one says to a population do
this there is not only no guarantee that
it will do it but also there is simply
no guarantee that it can do it end quote
because of the uncertainty of the
complex capacity of a population the
relation of the state to population
begins to appear more and more like that
of a manager or administrator a
transition that began at least a hundred
years before the community mental health
centers but one which accelerated under
Johnson's Great Society and the
expansion of the albeit truncated
American welfare state during his time
in office to manage the population of
the mass Democratic state the federal
government employed the tools of social
science to study the features of the
populations heterogeneity in order to
assess its capacity to sustain the kind
of action the state described desired
productivity reproduction and by the mid
20th century consumption as well and
Steen pointed out the exercise of power
over a population requires closer
attention from the state in the
community mental health center program
and in similar programs the welfare
bureaucracy use statistics interviews
maps functional diagrams and other such
techniques of poverty knowledge at the
federal level the success of the
community mental health center program
was charted by a saturation of each
census tract toward the goal of
providing a Center for each catchment
area
each American citizen was considered a
potential patient regardless of age race
gender or as I mentioned before the
ability to pay for care the image on
this slide then is the map that Clyde
Dorset used to track the progress of
community mental health center
construction once a grant was approved
and a facility was under construction
the catchment area was colored in yellow
and a pink pin was stuck in the map
later a blue pin replaced the pink one
when the building was completed the
image of the map was used as the cover
of an ni MH pamphlet about the program
called a citizen's guide to the
community mental health centers act the
representation of national progress was
a fitting poster child for the program
in that it was explicitly intended to
replace the broken system of state
mental health hospitals with an
enlightened federal effort at the urban
level the NIH required applicants to
show that they had considered
demographic trends juvenile delinquency
rates surrounding income levels
and the location of other health
resources in the area being increasingly
an outpatient program the facilities
needed to attract patients and their
families on a voluntary basis in order
to do so the facilities needed to
understand who they were serving you
might call it their audience or their
market perhaps population fits best the
image of the institution was an
important part of appealing to the local
population and Dorset and the other
architects and psychologists realized
that they would need to design something
very different from the restricted
inpatient psychiatric hospitals of the
past in the 1960s the image that needed
to be avoided was that of the giant
buildings constructed in the 19th
century as hospitals for the insane but
also and increasingly it meant modern
hospitals and the psychiatric wards that
they housed most commonly at least were
these so-called block style modern
hospitals in the United States that were
built after World War two under another
large federal construction program known
as the hilbert and legislation the
hilbert encodes practically required a
single wide corridor with doors on both
sides to satisfy the requirements for
modern medical equipment as well as
egress for all the non ambulant patients
the resulting form was typically a
single block a monolithic shape often
communicating its separation from
context through a plinth or open first
storey in contrast the community
health center architects developed a new
institutional typology able to
communicate an image of welcoming to the
patient which they attempted to do
through soft transitions from inside and
out as expressed by Dorset in a series
of patterns he developed in
collaboration with Christopher Alexander
patterns which were eventually published
in pattern language with credit given to
Dorset the typology also communicated
its softness and welcoming and contrasts
with the block style through a formal
articulation of programmatic elements
which reduced the monolithic appearance
of the building the articulated forms
index the scale of the human activities
within from single patient rooms to
gathering spaces in the 1967 publication
of the design fete Dorset and the other
designers express their goals in terms
of the theories of James Stirling and
Louie Kahn regarding the importance of
achieving a quote direct expression and
quote of programmatic volumes the idea
was to have the shape of the program
elements visible from the exterior as
well as being legible in the plans
community mental health center
architecture involved numerous attempts
to soften the long and flexible ward
hallway of the block style hospital
shown here enlarging it into lounges and
twisting it into circular arrangements
often the design work to articulate
individual treatment rooms and patient
bedrooms to bring intimacy and territory
into the anonymous forms in some cases
individual pavilions or lobes were
created as in this scheme by each HOD
wheeler of curtains and will in other
cases the hallways
was turned into a central lounge space
and territories were marked off with
columns and fixed furniture as in this
image
additionally individual elements were
often articulated with thicker walls as
in this plan which was part of
McKinley's scheme for continuous form
which I mentioned earlier
in short programmatic transparency had a
crucial function in the community mental
health center architecture namely it
allowed the architect to argue that the
forum responded to the patient's within
and to the psychiatrist's understanding
of the use of the facility through such
tailored forms the architect community
communicated to patients and the NIH
bureaucracy that the design was
responsive to program and the patient
population wallenstein anova and others
have described the hospitals of the
twenty
century as the laboratories of new
biopolitical strategies but by the 1960s
the site of research seems to have moved
on to the permeable institution of the
community mental health center now
acting as a new site of research for the
American welfare state as it expanded
its skill with the techniques of
psychology sociology and of course
pharmaceuticals the result was a softer
form of control and a softer
architecture at well as well at times it
was literally softer and at times merely
more responsive to the push and pull of
the patient populations it served the
permeable institution lured the
boundaries of inside and outside
replacing physical restraints with a
complex of urban architectural and even
chemical systems of attention and
management the architecture of the
community mental health centers was both
a manifestation of the population-based
governance of the American welfare state
and a new technology for attending to
the welfare of its population as the
size of the bureau Braddock
bureaucratic apparatus increased and the
state came increasingly to exercise
power at a very fine level of resolution
any given member of the population would
find the government more attentive or
responsive to his or her needs while at
the same time being controlled by more
complicated and more intimate means but
for purposes of this conference what
might be the most important point to
observe is the way that formal
strategies combined with social science
to produce a new if short-lived site of
bio political research for it was this
blend of disciplinary knowledge which
enabled the community mental health
centers to act as they did serving as an
architectural mediator between a mass
Democratic state and its population in
an age when form began to follow
Thorazine
thank you all and again I must say it
really is a privilege to have the
opportunity to moderate and discuss such
a rich set of papers there really is
probably too much to talk about a couple
of days to begin with just you know sort
of general questions that I know in
advance and ground it and maybe as
others are thinking about their
questions got it in some specifics from
from each of your papers you know the
question of the relationship
historically and in a sense in principle
as well between state formations and
other types of formations political
juridical etc sometimes accumulating in
transnational or extra stable forms it
seems to me that there are traces in in
each case of these sort of dynamics in
but probably they require kind of
historical specification and maybe like
that and and I wonder whether that might
in turn then lead on to other questions
that come into the papers that have to
do that implicate architecture in very
interesting and I think maybe somewhat
familiar but also a little bit in
unfamiliar way so I'll try to explain
that too so the first would be have to
do with this sort of recognition of
moments I mean in as for example in
Trish's lists the lists of these various
moments in the formation and reformation
of
quit sequence of Lisp it's a different
face on the bows r1 and but you know the
moment were the one one that stood up
stood out in this sense for me was the
supposed 29 moment in which the state
becomes a more active patron clearly in
response to two economic transformations
that are going on at large that have to
do with the sort of international
capital markets and that was expressed
in French so so there there's something
going on in quote unquote the private
markets that the state seems to just
respond to but certainly there's more at
play there then in Poland in the 1970s
and Anna's talk the appearance of these
competitions as a seeming you know
alternative or antidote you know
Kafkaesque some experiences of the state
bureaucrats as they try to build the
building but but you know the diagram
says I mean there's already the drawings
that these fantastic set of drawings
that you show you know if you think that
that diagram next to those the drawings
of the competition entries register
another language which we might also
associate with another set of patrons
clients and historical processes namely
though they I mean I'm thinking about
the super graphics and this sort of
highways and namely those of the
suburbanization and of countries like
the United States at the kind of
internalization of transportation
systems in the language of architecture
but also in of signs and symbols you
know kind of quite in a sense it's stark
contrast in the early nineteen seventies
to this sort of
flat and mute sort of expressions the
black and white right of the sort of
panel acts tunnel construction that was
yeah exactly right so so I'm thinking
about you know about the architecture
shopping malls and things like that and
again you know the different set of
agents that end clients and factories
and forces that that are there and then
finally in the context of the mental
health community centers without that
joy is talking about the presence of
pharmaceutical corporations
in collaboration with the state like
those ads that you show and then by
extension they of the role that
architecture plays in some in some sense
representing and inviting a
participation and not just with the
state but also with with literally
literally and physically bio politically
with the the output the production of
corporations the blue pills so so in you
know and in all of these cases there
seems to be a set of relationships
that's what I'm sort of getting at and
if there if there is something called a
state or you know Bureau or a kind of
political organization operating in in
any of these situations it is operating
in relation to other other developments
that I think we could stay at Barker
texture mediates architecture seems
indeed whether through the organization
of the production of architecture or
through the building's themselves or
other such things immediate so I I
wanted to ask you to invite you to
reflect a little bit on those mediations
you know between
in the organization and during this
period there would be more flexibility
into finance for example where the
compensation could be in fragmentation
every every chapter and what's going on
society the culture of the government
more large so I'll try to be brief about
something that's actually complex I show
just a little bit that list of ministers
her seventeen years these are only guys
who were sort of in charge of national
education and with the instability there
was a real at the end of the Third
Republic that the Parliament was really
in crisis and unable to function at many
certain moments and starting already in
the late 1920s there's a moment when
they abdicate their powers and hand over
to this president the cool side this
kind of super Prime Minister they right
to legislate without going through the
Parliament and this is more more the
case of what happens in the 1930s and at
the moment the big reform of John Jay
has passed in 1938 its name was the
decree law it's not a lot to decree law
because this is a moment when the
Parliament has abdicated and so the
decrees laws are passed without
Parliament's approval and that's
something that the government I mean
here the government means the group of
ministers and we have to kind of be
careful when you get into these words
government literally means the ministers
and the president the cool side so so
when the government passes this law it
scene is absolutely necessary to
modernize state functioning and to
improve the economics spending the 1930s
is also a period where generally in the
culture in France there's a lot of
problems and the citizens are expecting
the government to solve their problems
there was a kind of a political this is
when in a sense sort of the the date of
1940 or 1945 in a sense does it make
sense when you're looking at the French
situation
because it's really around the late 20s
when the citizens start to say you guys
have to do something you have to fix
these problems you have to fix the
economy France had a fairly closed
economy in relation to the rest of the
world at the at the time kind of behind
in terms of sort of economic development
which meant that the big crash affected
them much later yeah but when it hit
because you know these things that
protected them in the end they didn't
have the tools to come out of it they
were one of the last countries to come
out of it
so there's a lot of complicated things
and with the holes this whole sort of
dream of centralizing State Building
Control which was sort of created at the
revolution and goes in and out through
the you know 175 years that this kind of
single buildings administration exists
yeah existed there were moments when
they were just because the profession of
the architect was not controlled until
1940 anyone could call themselves an
architect and make a building so there
were a lot of problems with you know
there are people who were basically
surveyors that would wouldn't act as
architects so there are a lot of
problems with building quality
construction which is why it was so
important to have something an organism
like the general council looking over
what was being built because otherwise
you just didn't know what you were gonna
get and they had Ministry buildings of
foundations that were failing and you
know battles with the city of Paris
about who is gonna repair subways
stations and streets and I mean it was
there was a it was a very kind of
complex scenario but sort of there was a
need really to control these things
because there was a lot of stuff going
on that just I mean for my response I
might tie it back to the question you
asked before the panel view with regard
to the 1970s because definitely in the
American condition 74 is a good stopping
point because a lot of this apparatus
becomes privatized at that point and
sort of the public welfare state sort of
seeds to a kind of private welfare state
and quite literally in this group of
architects and other sort of researchers
that I'm looking at a lot of them move
off into private consulting they're
still doing a lot of the same work Clyde
Dorset is still sort of approving
drawings for different organizations but
it's not within the National
Judith mental health the different
hospitals will hire him and he'll sort
of give them the same guidelines but
he's no longer a member of the state in
that sense and so there's there's quite
you know the research economy changes
very much and I think the drug companies
are part of it but in the early 60s it's
definitely the professional psychiatry
groups that have a lot of power in
pushing this and getting it started and
moving so I think that's another sort of
in addition to sort of companies and
other kinds of private groups the
professional the status of social
science changes so much in the early 60s
that I think that's another sort of you
you know state and social science
expertise and that kind of state
sponsored research economies definitely
no no yeah no you're all I think
exploring very very interesting inter
sees that you know kind of let's say I
haven't used in in in what seems to be a
question looming over this this
discussion which has to do I mean you
know to put it in this sort of more
abstract terms whether or not it in what
sense a state can be understood as a
form of enclosure right in other words
as a self-contained because in
particular in in both of your papers
partly because of the the political
economic situation that the actors were
operating under and the sort of
institutionalization of you know kind of
socialistic quasi socialist state that
in different ways as you say you know
sealed itself off for or reinvented or
reorganized its its institutions
produced the effect of a kind of outside
but maybe let's say historically
rather than metaphorically speaking the
that that that inside you know has been
shown you you should showed this to be
permeable but in different ways and that
seems in itself interesting and
important in in some sense in
demystifying the some of the hierarchies
that sort of let's say the bringing down
to earth the figure of the state it's
something other than a rhetorical
construction as a sort of material
practice in a sense that is you know
forms reform that says again
you're showing an architecture in you
know and obviously and by virtue of its
status as a matter of practice capable
of throwing up these kinds of
representations the arrows that the
super graphics and the panel act the the
you know the bozo facade that was
actually being produced by that
bureaucracy and indeed these very nice
happy humane team ten projects that show
it seems importantly situated in within
this relations in any event I I mean I'm
assuming that there are questions at
large so if you
question for Ana your presentation of
the design factories is striking and how
some of the labor forms seem to emulate
construction work on Stalinist regimes
and the so called shock workers working
by norms and I was wondering if there
was also any pressure on draftsman to
work quickly enough to exceed the norm
in other words to sort of engage in what
construction work was called socialist
competition if you know that the culture
of the work the regime of the worker who
was the intellectual as a result so
placing creating training architects
into office workers to bring them kind
of see them present it not as
intellectuals and artists but as again
in this case office workers but they
were definitely especially in this
period which is extreme of against
subjecting them to the same you know
scientific management and exceeding the
norms definitely bringing them in the
design before the do so they would be
financially rewarded for exceeding norms
yes and then I I have to qualify this is
a very appealing
- you're thinking of comments the it's
what we often do and I'm definitely did
this year is that we create this kind of
a monolithic picture of the communist
Poland and nothing changed for you know
forty years this was extremely because
of the tension within the society
because this was not a popular of course
regime there were this process of
tension and then negotiation between the
authorities and the in this case
architects that there was always this
issue that in order to stay in power
there always has to be some kind giving
in little bit just to just to suppress
their you know violent revolution
against so again in certain moments in
time for a few years that would be for
example prizes for exceeding that this
might change in three years and then
would be absolutely like you know
completely different set of rules so I
don't want to generalize no I absolutely
understand this is a Stalinist system
within a very specific point of time but
I think it's important to basically
state that it was a monolithic system at
any point in time given the government's
position and the way of working
construction is that if you exceeded the
norm you were paid very well forth and
the government would use that to
establish the new norm which meant that
the standards of production you know a
proper kind of understanding this is the
worker you know the bricklayer exceeding
the norm and becoming the hero and
having his you know portrait being
operated in the you know patterns the
same thing with architects thanks very
much
apparently we maybe will take them all
will gather questions bureaucrats but
you know the question of agency that
disgusting is another one that I think
circulates and I wanted to you know just
highlight that and maybe that's gonna
come up in the other questions it's also
it was noticeable that the office
workers in your slides were there were
many women in this law it's in contrast
to the middle-aged male constituency of
the enlightened program so anyway there
there is there certain hydrogenating
okay one two three yeah I'm gonna let
you all organize the questions and then
yeah you should I'm struck by the fact
that you should architect as this sort
of very repressed figure you know I mean
this creative figure but then he's been
oppressed by this state bureaucracy but
if we consider how Reynolds was saying
that state not as completely enclosed
you know super entity which is able to
control everything but it's always you
know whose boundaries are fluorescent is
always being challenged from different
sides then how can we can we understand
this sort of contradictory figure of the
archetype it is changed by the state as
sort of having these two sides creative
and technical as a figure which manages
a certain risk you know that when things
go bad or things are not sort of
completely lining up there is this
element of creativity as you know the
figure of the genius which is
nevertheless allowed to continue within
this bureaucracy so instead of seeing it
as you know just simply taking the state
at its worse that it's you know work
that it's oppressing this figure we
should perhaps can consider there it's
actually maintaining this figure in this
dual state to manage certain sort of
risks
well I want to thank everyone for their
wonderful presentations but again I have
to direct my question to Ana and it and
it's in it speaks to a little bit of
this the the idea of the inside-out and
in kind of the nutritive state is in
closure because these design for bureaus
in Poland although they're not
monolithic the organizational structure
looks very familiar to you know the
structures in all of you know you
Central Europe and also the Soviet Union
so I would just ask you know what you
know if what is this particular
organizational mode and what's the role
of the Communist Party and how can we
say open this up beyond just the polish
example or if that is about if that
question is relevant to your project I
had a question for Tricia actually I was
very struck by the visuals of the lists
of administrators in your presentation
and I was just wondering whether they
could I mean with it with amidst all
this turmoil you know they were all
leftists like most of them you showed
that by admitted the administrators
right they had a vision right they were
a political but they had a vision could
they put an architectural forum on it
court was it just so chaotic that they
could just barely like control the
foundations the buildings that were
getting what I was suggesting and trying
to make up maybe I should have
emphasized it a little more that I that
I I kind of wanted to see both sides and
I definitely what I was with the
diagrams that I was showing you is sort
of and the the that this was really the
attack and the the overemphasizing I
think or focusing on how this is not you
know what this does
to the architecture and what a terrible
terrible place these beers were was kind
of it's there was a political statement
on the part of the underlining the issue
was here to bring down to the regime you
know in the in that you know in the long
view this was a critique of the regime
to you know political statement really
and it doesn't reflect that they were
actually dead dysfunctional they were
just dead horrible if you know and I
mean it's not it's just focusing on this
one issue that this is the bureaucracy
is just overwhelming and there's just no
creative thinking involved in what it
was being done it's a way for architects
they could they could not criticize the
system itself there was no credit it's
the system the socialist state cannot be
criticized that it's illegal but
criticize how it function or there is
something wrong in inna we earlier they
were presenting themselves as architects
who want to build socialist architecture
but they are not allowed because
something is wrong with the system if
you know I mean so underlying issue of
this overemphasizing you know years
after years is everything is wrong there
were problems are in the bureau's is
really again a polka critique of the
entire system that was allowed to be
published and Ricky yes everything goes
to back to Moscow
even the name master yes the priest it's
based on Soviet models and they were you
know just probably pamphlets on how
these organ the spirits were functioning
in in the Soviet Union and they were
definitely modeled in Poland and
probably another parts of Eastern Bloc
as well again I am done I don't feel
qualified to speak of the and I didn't
have any materials to say that this is
modeled on this specific but definitely
the president is the the Soviet Union
okay there's two parts to that question
and I think yes sort of this pursuit of
the reform policy does align with a left
or Center left policy which does
correspond to sort of this continuing
nomination of these ministers within
this kind of thinking the civil servants
in a sense were apolitical
but because the ministers didn't come in
and dramatically change things they
could continue to pursue things in the
continuous way within a sort of larger
spirit coming from these sort of parties
that dominated control of the National
Education Ministry secondly in terms of
the aesthetic aspect of this period you
know the Bozarth gets kind of a bad rap
during this period because it's seen as
being all about traditional architecture
and usually the Palais de Chaillot from
the expo of 37 is the poster child of
architecture and official architecture
which is kind of a shame because it's
actually much more interesting what's
being produced although one of the
things that is difficult about this year
is these years is that the funding is so
awful
there's not a whole lot of public
architecture being built so it's hard to
sometimes test those things and it's
more apparent in some of the exhibitions
that are mounted
this time official exhibitions where you
really see the diversity that's being
sort of promoted and the the Popular
Front and even before the sort of last
ten years of the Third Republic there's
a decision made explicit decision made
within the Bozarth administration to not
take sides and what was a very polarized
architectural menu there were the
modernist versus kind of the the
traditionalists and the the profession
in a sense was being torn apart by these
kinds of debates and so the bazaar
administration basically said we're
gonna choose what was called the Toit's
name blah the third way which is
pluralist and they made an agenda to be
pluralist and they wanted both sort of
modern and it's kind of in between spit
stuff and then they wanted this you know
more traditional stuff they wanted
everyone to have a place they didn't
want to have to pick sides and this was
definitely out there for the expo of
1937 if you look at the French pavilions
they go from very very very modern to
very very very regionalist and it's an
incredible array of diverse production
that's shown coming from French
architects that's shown to the world and
it's a shame that it's just shy oh
that's today we remembered as sort of
the production of you know official
production in the period because I mean
the pad laid there although it's an
incredible building it looks like a good
being built in 1950 and he knows nobody
talks about these things because
unfortunately a lot of them got torn
down but the agenda was to show this
Peroni
I will think again presenters and and
ask just in the in the spirit of keeping
the conversation going because I know
there are other questions we
collectively apologized for not being
able to take all of them but in order to
kind of maximize our chances as we go I
would propose that we take a shorter
break between this and the next panel
essentially you know sort of five
minutes or so
and you know so as we transition the
next panel and start getting ready and
and so we'll be starting okay thank you
again it was a great start that was
great